and he did it he did it what's next
knight c5
knight c5 check the king gets the d4
and then both sides are crazy
oh my god it's the most beautiful mate
i've ever seen oh my god he's got mate
oh my god that's beautiful wait wait
wait go back to c5 go back to c5
knight f5 check knight f5 check king c4
knight d6 check came back to d4 knight
he's the 96's mate
oh he found it with three seconds knight
at five
that is gorgeous that is sam copeland
game of the week copeland the knights
have done some work baby girl
and the knights have delivered mate oh
my god that is
oh my gosh i'm so glad i'm not on camera
right now because it would look
inappropriate
with what i'm doing over here holy
i just love mojo batman
that was the highest my voice has ever
gone this stuff was so
freaking awesome